sur certaines routes secondaires il
faudra rouler plus tranquille sous leurs
imperméables les panneaux affichent la
nouvelle limite maximale 80 km au lieu
de 90 sur les routes secondaires sans
séparateur central
une mesure qui ne soulèvent pas ici
d'opposition frontale
bon alors mais tu as 80 et puis ils ont
envie de rouler à 200 ça prend l'exemple
des jeunes et on mettra après c'est une
question de comme on dit respecter le
code de la route
ça vous pose pas de problème vous allez
respecter exact déjà qu'il ya même
vachement de fonctions déjà en temps
normal la fin ça va pas non plus changé
je pense beaucoup sur la circulation en
soi et avec une route principale en
martinique il ya beaucoup de bouchons
donc je pense pas que ça soit très
judicieux cet abaissement de la
limitation vise à réduire le nombre de
morts sur les routes 400 - selon le
gouvernement qui ne lésine pas sur la
communication 13 m c'est ce qui vient de
lui sauver la vie
en roulant à 80 km/heure au lieu de 90
vous gagnez 13 mètres en cas de freinage
mais en martinique difficile d'avoir une
estimation sur les vies potentiellement
sauver il n'ya pas d'étude la grande
ligne droite des trois îles et sera donc
traitée comme cette route sinueuse de
saint joseph un avocat philippe l'acide
conteste la cohérence de la mesure il ya
tout en pourcentage tout un pan
d'accidents qu'il est absolument pas
traité par les mesures qui sont prises
aujourd'hui qui sont évidemment des
mesures faites pour renflouer les
caisses de l'état et laisser penser que
l'on agit les nouveaux panneaux sont
installés près des quatre radars pour
les autres routes cela reste à faire et
aux frais de la ctm dans l'hexagone la
présidente du conseil général de la
creuse valérie simonet a refusé de
financer ses nouveaux panneaux qu'en est
il chez nous malgré tout les relances
nous n'avons pas eu de réponse de la ctm
une chose est sûre panneaux ou pas la
règle est désormais de 80 km